so 17
million views by the age of 17
is this possible well it is and i'm
excited because i have
evan de dio with us here today on
the youtube made simple show my name is
heather torres and i
am your host i am so excited to get into
today's
live interview but if you're watching on
the replay
let me know down in the comments where
you're watching from and if you're
watching
live let me know where you are watching
from now
this episode of the youtube made simple
show is actually brought to you by
our next upcoming challenge here at
think media we have a youtube impact
challenge this is a five day free
challenge
that you can sign up for over the next
five days starting on
may 18th you will get access to
free content and we are also going to be
giving away
a youtube studio that's right you will
have the chance to enter
to win a brand new youtube studio with a
camera and lighting and microphone and
all of the fun things that come along
with that so
if you have not already signed up for
you can register right now
for the youtube impact challenge at
ytimpack.com i'll tell you more about
that
after today's interview but i'm excited
to bring up my guest
evan de dio who is a speaker musician
and social media advisor
he's actually helped multiple youtube
channels reach
over 10 times their goal and including
his church's youtube channel
encountered today which is now more than
17
million views he runs multiple youtube
channels at the age of 17
and he's passionate about seeing
churches using social media
to bring revival and reformation
evan welcome to the youtube made simple
show how you doing
miss heather i am doing fantastic and
it's so good to be on the show today
i am a full of energy i've got a whole
cup of coffee over here watch out
everyone
so you're lucky evan um i'd love to know
i mean 17
hello can we just like honor the fact
that you are already a hustler like
really diving into youtube but tell
everyone on the show
how did you get started in youtube what
was your journey to
17 million and beyond now views on
youtube
yeah i believe that starting correctly
is important and if you if you didn't
start correctly don't worry there's
always you've always got another chance
but
i started in an interesting place
without knowing anything about youtube
without having ever been
on youtube i was in a band and
i wanted to learn a song and i wanted to
learn
the guitar solo to that song that song
was hold by hand by hooting the blowfish
come on somebody can can we get anything
in the comments about hootie and the
blowfish
taking you back to the 90s and i wanted
to learn the guitar solo because i'm in
this band
i want to i want to do the song well and
i look up on youtube how to play the
guitar solo
to hold my hand up and i couldn't find
it so i did a video
and there you're seeing the video right
now me and my bedroom
with my bed i didn't even do my hair the
lighting is weird i stuck my phone
literally i put my phone in a lamp
like there was a lamp sitting there and
i kind of stuck it in between the edge
it wasn't supposed to be there and it
fell
a few times yeah we got some people
talking about darius rucker in the chat
and my phone fell a few times so i and i
took me probably five hours to edit the
video on my phone
but i got the content and i was excited
i posted it on youtube
no tags i did have a decent thumbnail
which is still the thumbnail today if
you want to look at it
and i i just posted it and
a week later i posted the part two how
to play the rhythm section because i was
thinking well
if they want to learn the guitar solo
maybe they also want to learn the rhythm
section
you see my weird intro there i had no
idea what i was doing
and so i i figured hey maybe this will
help someone and
if you're watching this and you're just
now getting started i want your goal not
to be
getting thousands of views i don't want
it to be making money
of course you need to think long term
you need to think about what am i going
to do five years from now
will this be profitable for me but i
want you to start thinking about
am i going to bring value to someone's
life
and my vision from the start was this
video
is going to show another kid my age how
to play the guitar solo because there's
no one else out there teaching it
so that was my vision from the start and
then i did a video about fidget spinners
and if you've been on think media for a
little while you know you need to
keep it niche down you need to make sure
you're in a niche and you're not going
all over the place i didn't know
anything about that
then one day my dad showed me a video of
this guy named sean cannell
talking about affiliate marketing i had
no idea oh yep there's a fidget spinner
video
my bed is a mess you see the lamps in
the background that i suck the phone in
yeah it's hard for me to watch and
i got i saw this video of this sean
cannell guy and i was like
can i watch more of his videos first
youtube channel i subscribed to was
think media
and i started learning wait it's good to
be in a niche
so i picked get the guitar niche and i
didn't realize that was a very populated
niche and i changed later
but i started listening to think media
and i started just
kind of enveloping myself in
think media and all the videos around
there around there and then i found
video influencers
i watched all the videos i'm serious
every single video
that was on there in 2017 or 2018 i
watched all of them
and finally i went to my pastor and i
was like
hey is it okay if i try out some of
these things on the church's youtube
channel
it hadn't been anything serious there
were a few videos on there
and this video specifically was on there
and i'd like to show it to you real fast
if i could
do it real quick um this video
it was it was a video by a man named dr
lisa sumrall you don't know who he is
that's okay
and i i asked him if i could change it
so i
changed the thumbnail to this and
looking at it now i'm kind of horrified
by the way that looks but that video is
our most viewed video today with 1.2
million views seriously 1.2 million
views and i learned from that day that
something could happen on youtube and
people can
actually reach people on youtube so that
was my start and from then on i started
doing more on the youtube channel
that's a long answer to a short question
but
so so good evan i loved that you just
got started you were like i'm gonna just
figure this out and then
uh you've been able over the past few
years to uh
not only just advise other churches on
youtube and social media and how to do
that
but you've really grown your church's
youtube channel to over 17
million views and we've got three tips
for
uh new youtubers right advice for new
youtubers because
now that you've done this journey for a
while and done it in different niches
right not only just the church niche but
your own
i just really wanted you to come on
today and help people with maybe some
advice that they haven't heard before
because
everyone's going to hear the things that
we talk about like consistency
and making sure you've got the right
topics and all those things but i loved
the angle that you had
based on what you were doing and i love
like john said you know can
can church or ministry be a niche
absolutely john that's exactly what evan
was able to do
and yes wow 1.2 million views
really cool so let's get to our tips
today evan tip number one
is use polarizing and trending topics
talk about this for a new youtuber and
why this is so
important yeah and i think it's
interesting what he just asked about can
a church of minister being a niche i
think
that the bible is a great niche and that
leads into what we're talking about here
because
the bible is very polarizing and maybe
you're in another niche maybe
you're not talking about the bible
necessarily but there are polarizing
topics in whatever niche you're
in and i found that polarizing topics
get a great click-through rate and they
get great engagement
now you might be thinking oh that sounds
great evan well it's not the type of
engagement that you might be used to
because polarizing means that some
people won't like the
side that you take and so there might be
some negative comments
um with of course there are people you
need to hide but
don't be too concerned about that
because they're engaging on your video
that is engagement and that's helping
your video get forward
so polarizing topics what does this mean
it's like trending topics and i like how
the think media podcast has talked about
writing the wave um of a trending topic
and i highly recommend searching through
the archives on here
and finding that because it's great
information and
so when you start doing polarizing
topics expect some negative engagement
but expect engagement nonetheless it's
going to be good engagement
and let's say i mean politics is very
polarizing
if you're talking about the bible you've
got the end times that can be very
polarizing
both together could be very polarizing
maybe you're in the cooking niche and
one person says
this recipe should be this cooked this
way
like on the grill with charcoal and
another person says no it should be
cooked you know with what however else
people cook things on the grill
you can tell i don't know much about a
grill but that's polar that's polarizing
and and people are going to have
different responses to it
and one thing i'd say in your thumbnail
and your title don't automatically give
away what side you're on
make it so they need to find out in the
video and
that way it delivers a payoff in the
video because if they find out
no you shouldn't use coal on the
thumbnail and they believe you should
use coal
while you're cooking chicken or whatever
they're less likely to click on it
because
you know you you disagree with them but
once once you get them on the video
that's powerful and
you get engagement so good that actually
leads into
number two when growing a youtube
channel as a brand new youtuber and
as a veteran youtuber i think number two
is so
important and that is to encourage
engagement on
your videos there's so many ways you can
do this right that's leave a comment
this is like and subscribe but
how do you as a youtuber as someone
who's helping another channel doing your
own channel
how do you encourage engagement on
videos and why is this important for new
youtubers
yes so i speak with churches a lot about
um
this specifically they want to know how
did you grow your church's youtube
channel it doesn't make any sense
you're a small church from the backwoods
of north carolina and i tell them
because
we've got a family in our church
that i explained to them how the youtube
algorithm works
and this is this is interesting because
not all your family
members care about how the youtube
algorithm works but a lot of them care
about you
and they'd be willing to learn so what
do i mean by that i explained to
the church congregation that when you
like a video
you are helping that video get to
someone else that needs to watch it
when you're watching all the way through
you're promoting this video
to get in front of more people and i
think you know the position a lot of
churches
take is it's youtube is a place to store
content
and maybe that's what you think youtube
is a good place to store content i like
what the bible says in the book of joel
he talks he prophesies that they're
going to beat their plowshares
into swords now what does this mean
maybe you don't know what i'm talking
about in the book of joel what is all
this
plowshares are
make managing what you already have so
plowshares are for
make sure you're bringing in the harvest
on your land swords are for going out
and
taking new land and i explain this to
the congregation
and even the even the older people that
aren't into technology at all
they got it and they realize when i
comment i'm
helping this video get to someone else
when i like it
i'm i am on a mission now to get this to
evangelize because it's it's evangelism
social media when you're commenting
whether it's a good video or a bad video
you're
evangelizing that video to more people
and so that's what
what i explained to them and what i
think you could do is talk to your
family members
maybe you don't have family members
maybe you've got a friend maybe you've
got
five friends explain to them hey could
you could you turn the video on
and maybe just set it down to the side
you don't even have to listen to it
you can turn the volume down maybe like
it real quick
and just watch all the way through and
once it's done move on about your day
you could be doing the dishes while it's
going
and you'll be surprised how much of that
helps because
you you are helping that video get to
more people and i
i hope that makes sense because getting
help is so is so vital and
once once they once the people that care
about you realize this
they are very interested in helping so
true and i love that your example was
really
you know in the church in the
congregation but this really goes for
all niches and all creators right yes
meaning like
if you're in the cooking niche you
should be connected to other people
in facebook groups or in your in your
own life or
out in meetups whatever that looks like
where you can start to ask for
engagement you know i think about tony
and his wife cami here on the think
media team
and whenever she has a new video out i
don't cook but i watch it in support
because i love what she's doing and when
you have people around you supporting
you
that's the type of engagement but here's
the thing you've got to encourage
the engagement right as a content
creator it doesn't necessarily come
natural to be like look at me look at
what i'm doing but when you teach them
the why like you did evan you taught
them the why
that's where that came from and i love
what john said he said this is so
helpful i'm a pastor
and so and a social media person so john
you've got to connect with evan
because evan does this yeah i'd love to
help
i love that and uh evan i just i'm so
encouraged by the way that you've taken
what you've learned at think media and
applied it to your niche that really is
what we love to teach
is that it these tips this advice is
good for
any youtuber in any niche you're just
showing your example
and number three is a really great i
know you talked about the first
thumbnail that you changed where all of
a sudden that video blew up to 1.2
million
views you've definitely studied
thumbnails you actually are working on
some things in the back end around
thumbnails but
number three make faces more prominent
in your thumbnails walk through
why this is important and some other
maybe thumbnail advice that you have for
new youtubers
yes so i'm like you mentioned i'm
working on some things in the background
talking about um an online course for
creating good thumbnails and you can
subscribe to my email list if you want
to
learn more about that in the future it's
not out yet but thumbnails i have spent
so much time studying thumbnails because
thumbnails are the most important thing
i would say you could do to a well shot
video
so let's say you have a fantastic video
that solves
all the world's problems but it doesn't
have a good thumbnail
it's not gonna do good it's and it's not
going to get to the right people
so spending time on your thumbnail is so
so vital and people want to know about
thumbnails for gaming channels yes this
goes for every
every type of channel youtube is forever
working on
the viewer intent and the viewer
interaction with videos
they are always thinking about how can
we make this easier for the person
that is on youtube right now how can we
keep them on youtube longer
so they're always working on that and
thumbnails keep on
getting so and so much more important
and i don't i don't want you to neglect
the importance of what i'm talking about
today because if you if you haven't been
investing time in your thumbnails you
need to start so let's
let's talk about some practical tips
when you're shooting a thumbnail which
by the way don't
i recommend not just using a still from
a video unless you have to
but when you're shooting thumbnails make
sure your face is prominent and that's
that is the first tip because
having a face that's prominent in the
thumbnail usually does a whole lot
better and i've
i basically just copied you know good
artist copy great artist steel
i just copied what think media was doing
and kind of put my own twist on it
and it started to work and my
click-through rate is now probably
i believe an average of around eight
percent on the church's youtube channel
because and that's if if you don't know
much about click-through rate the
average is between two and five percent
so eight percent is pretty good
on certain videos i have an average of
15 and 16
click-through rate because i will spend
an hour and a half on a thumbnail
i try to limit myself to two hours but i
will spend an hour and a half
making sure the face is in the right
spot making sure the face is close up to
the camera
that the eyes are visible sometimes i
like to put a white
outline around the person if possible i
don't use
any text at all because again youtube
has a special algorithm designated to
thumbnails
so they will read your facial
expressions they will read the text on
your thumbnails and i think a lot of
people don't realize this they just put
whatever in their thumbnails
but you and you spend more time on your
tags and you do your thumbnails
your thumbnails youtube looks at your
thumbnails just as much as they look at
your tags
they have something called cloud vision
and i love the work derral eves
if you haven't heard of derral eves i
highly recommend looking him up because
he talked
a lot about cloud vision i believe it's
called cloud vision that
literally looks at all of
your thumbnail your facial expression
whether you're happy whether you're sad
whether the text on the thumbnail is
relevant to the video
is it click baity they go through each
an individual frame of your video to
make sure
you're talking about what you say you're
talking about so when you're doing your
thumbnail
someone's asking um about an app to use
give it a go with baking with amy an app
to use i like to use
adobe spark on my phone it's fairly easy
to use i think canva has an app you can
use
and they're fairly inexpensive photoshop
has an app as well so you can look into
that if you'd like but
um i i love to talk about
when i'm talking with churches and with
people that want to learn more about
thumbnails
i love to talk about seo on their
thumbnails and how
youtube looks at your thumbnail they
look at your keywords in your thumb
so think media talks a lot about
keywords and how important they are
and once you start implementing that i
highly recommend researching keywords
for your thumbnail
and not just using the same thing in
your thumbnail as you did in your title
but finding keyboards that are getting
searches that
you can put on your thumbnail
specifically that you know of course not
very wordy but
keep it clean basically i like to make
it as appealing as possible
and if you can't catch what the video is
about with the thumbnail within the
first two seconds of looking at it
then you need to redo the thumbnail so
good oh my gosh evan by the way you were
dropping some
really big knowledge bombs there when
you're talking about
researching uh the actual keyword for
your thumbnail separately we teach that
here
um at think media but we're gonna be
talking about keyword research
inside of our youtube impact challenge
also so i'm really excited to
um for that to happen next week but i
really loved how you said that the
facial expressions
matter and especially when it comes to
making the faces more prominent
it's really about getting that
expression and i was coaching someone uh
today evan
and i was telling them you know their
their thumbnails their face was actually
it was like a bunch of their body
and so their face was so small and i was
like crop
in here's the hack shoulders up
shoulders up
is the image not body shoulders up
because
that allows for the eyes to be more
prominent and the face to be more
prominent and the emotions to really
uh be a part of that and evan you just
sound like you're already a part of
think media
i love it it's so good if you're liking
this video go ahead and
click the like button let us know down
in the comments below
uh are you just starting your youtube
channel yes or no
and if you've already started drop your
youtube channel so we can go over
and check it out i'd love to uh check
out your youtube channel
but evan you had a bonus tip for new
uh youtubers because this was something
that really was the catalyst into
you becoming a professional youtube
coach right you are
helping other churches you're really
helping on social media you are um
actually producing
content yourself but you're also running
other channels
as a job as a 17 year old i'm i'm like
can i meet your mom
that's what i want to tell you you have
a bonus tip and
i love this tip because i believe in
this so much as well
and the bonus tip is to get a coach
why do you believe in getting a coach
and what is it done for you
so you know i started youtube three and
a half years ago about
around there and i found think media and
that changed my life
and sean cannell became a mentor
and whenever you're looking for a coach
i don't want you to just think of
somebody you can listen to i want you to
think somebody you can listen to
learn from and act on not just
take what they say and say wow that's
that's a good piece of advice
and never actually act on it never
actually do anything with it
so whenever you're looking at think
media there are so many great channels
and i've heard so many people
like sean's given so many examples of
people that are like
well i've tried i've tried your tips and
it's not it's just not working
and he goes and looks at their channel
and there's two videos
well yeah it's not working because
you're not working it you've got to be
persistence it's it's a game of
attrition and if you don't have someone
that you can look up to
you you'll get kind of surrounded by the
cloud and
you'll you'll you'll feel burnt out and
really that feeling of burnout will not
be real and you won't have a coach to
tell you
hey you need to keep going you know a
coach isn't
a coach isn't some nice school teacher
that is like oh you can do it timmy
i believe in you no a coach is gonna
tell you what are you doing
get up off that ground just keep making
videos
and that's that's exactly what the think
media team has been for me
because i'm not just hearing what
they're saying i'm
acting on what they're saying so that's
what i want you to do i want you
to start with think media i want you to
start
just listening to every i don't mean you
have to get on a personal phone call
with them
learn what they already have given for
free and then
move on from there and i think the
impact challenge coming up
is the best place to do that yeah i told
you before the live stream it's
interesting
about a year ago this time with the
first challenge y'all did
was really when everything started
taking off it's when i joined vra
come on vra family in the comments
um it's when i did that that everything
took off
and it's not just because i took the
challenge it's because
i was in the challenge i took the advice
and i acted on it
so good and 17 million views later
the impact you guys have had around the
world
from just a tiny town right little tiny
town little tiny church
you guys were impacting millions of
lives and that's exactly what you can do
on youtube that's the that's the coolest
part i think about youtube is it
connects people
from around the world our next challenge
that evan was just talking about
um is coming up on may 18th so you can
actually sign up at ytimpack.com
it's free right evan you did a whole
challenge it's free it's amazing
and uh and then through that uh evan
actually became a part of our online
community our
online coaching and course program video
ranking academy but
you can do the entire challenge for free
which is something that i highly
recommend
um is your next step evan i just have to
say though
this whole setup is so crispy and i'm
sure people are like
how in the world is this 17 year old
rocking this sure mic
with the beautiful background like this
isn't where you started right
no no no no no so talk through kind of
the journey because i think people get a
misconception though
of even the setups and how we got to
this place and how you got to your place
um just just briefly what does that look
like
yeah so i didn't feel like of course you
know i didn't watch youtube so
i didn't have anything to base my
channel off of i was just
like if i can get in front of a camera
and talk to it then hey
i'm gonna do it so i put my camera in
selfie mode
i looked at the screen the whole time
you know you're not supposed to do that
you're supposed to look at the camera
and i that's what i started with and
from then on i realized
videography is actually a passion of
mine so i'm not saying videography has
to become a passion of yours don't get
me wrong you don't have to
have it as a job like i do videography
for people now because it is a passion
of mine
but i wanted to do things better
and that's that hunger is what got me to
this point today because
every single video there was something i
didn't like about it and
something that shane i mean dramatically
changed my life was something that
mr sean said he said all i want you to
do
is get one percent better with every
upload
and i was in the shower when he said
that i was like wait hold up
stop shampooing the hair sorry if that's
a little bit too much
it's tmi uh that's what i need to do
i need to get one percent better without
it's not like i'm gonna get there
tomorrow it's not like i'm gonna get
there within the next
year and two years later i'm here
i'm still working on getting one percent
better with every upload because
there's still something i need to fix
there's lighting i could add
i mean blue lighting there's something i
could do but it's not about the gear
it's about what you do with what you
have and getting one percent better with
that
and the new gear will come when you just
focus
you keep your shoulder to the plow you
don't try to you don't take a lot of
breaks you just keep working keep
pushing and getting one percent better
so that
that's what i did i'm using uh quick
gear rundown i'm using the sony a7c
with a 24 to 72.8 found this at an
antique store
that little edison bulb light i've got a
godox
light with a softbox there and the shore
mic so
that's basically what i'm doing here and
if you would like to learn more of
course you can find me on my youtube
channel but
people are agreeing with one percent
better with every upload in the chat so
i believe that's that's definitely an
important tip yes that's exactly what
i'm seeing well
i saw people in here saying they had
just started youtube about a month ago
maybe three months ago i haven't started
i'm new to youtube so evan
i would just love for you now that
you've been doing youtube for several
years
now that you've seen some success on
youtube now that you're coaching and
training and
working in this youtube space what
advice would you give to someone
just starting i know we went through
those three tips and that bonus tip but
i want you to just speak directly to the
people in the chat right now who are
here live with us
who are maybe feeling unmotivated or
scared or overwhelmed
with everything that you get to learn
when you start this youtube journey what
advice do you have for them
yes so i would say if you're just
getting started in fact let me know in
the chat put a yes if you're just
getting started on youtube or if you've
just been doing it for a little while
now
uh someone said brush your teeth while
listening to sean yes i've done that
before
my my piece of advice would be don't
give up on what works i've seen so many
people that ask for my advice and i give
it to them and they start
they go after it i mean they are doing
good thumbnails they're researching
titles they're using vid iq to find good
keywords and
they're doing all the things but they
after a month or two of doing it they
start to let off a little bit
and you know it's it's really easy to
just kind of take it easy it's really
easy to take it easy
that needs to be a t-shirt i need to
remember that
so don't let off the gas aim for that
vid iq score that is
100 out of 100. i've gotten that a few
times and
every video i do now you know whenever
you're planning for a live stream and
you're in vid iq vidiq gives you a score
and so i it's a 50 out of 50 and i've
gotten to the point where i'm getting a
50 out of 50 on every single video now
and i'm not letting up
i'm not changing the message i'm not
changing what i'm talking about i'm not
telling my pastor you need to talk about
this because it gets more engagement
i'm not changing the message i'm
changing the marketing and that's what
you need to do
change the marketing and don't stop with
what works keep doing what works and
keep your foot on the gas pedal
and i think that would be my advice for
someone that's just getting started
you're you
you need to be in it for the long haul
and that's what i i'm in it for the long
haul i know miss heather's in it for the
long haul
and you can join in by i think the
challenge is one of the best ways to get
in on the long haul because
you invest in your time you you invest
your time into it
and it becomes real to you so that
that's just a quick thought but
i love it and uh and we have someone
that said they'll buy the t-shirt
evan so when you make that bite
i love it so much cassidy said that's
good
awesome well evan hey this is where
people can find you tell them uh what
you're all about where they can find you
and uh and what you're up to next
yes so like i mentioned earlier i'm
working on my thumbnail e-course now my
youtube channel is all about
uh youtube for churches how to reach
more people with churches so if you're a
part of a church
if you know a church i think it'll be
really helpful to them for media
directors for pastors
pastors that wear many hats like john um
i believe pastor john was in the chat
yeah and
so that's my goal i'm here to help i do
live streams i'm in a season now where
i'm not doing as many live streams i'm
posting once a week at least
with some shorts but i plan on a lot
more content coming out on the summer
that i think is going to be very
important and of course there are
two and a half years worth of content
you can watch so you've got plenty of
things
to enjoy on the youtube channel and you
can sign up for my email list at my
website
at evantadio.com evan de dio
17 years old with over 17 million views
helping churches learn how to use social
media
evan thank you so much if you would like
to be a part of our uh
five day youtube challenge you can go to
um yt impact.com if you go to yt impact
wow i knew that was going to happen yep
if you could go to
ytnpak.com get signed up for that free
seven or so free five day challenge now
i'm all messed up i can't even give the
call to action evan
because the screen was going crazy yes
um you can go there
evan i just want to thank you so much
for um just being someone who took
massive action who took what was out on
the internet who took what was for free
who took your passion and really just
wanted to help people and i'm just so
encouraged and i saw so many people say
they were encouraged by
who you are and the work that you're
doing and the leader that you are
becoming so thank you so much for
joining me on the youtube made simple
show and we will catch you on the next
episode thanks so much bye